SEAN-MICHAEL LEWIS: Hello, and
welcome to my talk Do it live!
Fitbit's Zero-Downtime
Migration to GCP.
I'm Sean-Michael Lewis.
I'm Principal Software
Engineer at Fitbit.
And I was in charge of moving
our monolithic application
from our legacy managed hosting
to Google Cloud platform.
In today's talk, I'm going
to talk about what was unique
or what we felt was unique about
Fitbit's migration challenge.
We are going to
talk about how we
thought about users
in making decisions
to move for our migration.
Then we'll talk about the
technology and processes
that we added and affected
to make this happen.
We'll talk a little
bit about how it went,
which was quite well.
And then we'll
have some takeaways
that we think could
be useful for you,
should you be moving from
another cloud provider
or your own managed hosting
into Google Cloud Platform.
So, like many companies,
Fitbit started
with a monolithic application.
We had a single binary
that did all the things.
It is quite large.
It handles all of our traffic,
or it did for a long time.
And then, we started to
break it up into what
we call microservices.
It's pretty standard
when a company matures.
But while moving microservices
might be quite easy,
each service can do its own
thing, move its own data store,
figure things out and
move into the cloud,
a monolith is much
more challenging.
It's more challenging,
it's bigger, meatier,
it takes up about
70% of our traffic.
So moving it was quite hard.
So our migration wasn't going to
happen until the monolith move.
So let's talk
about our monolith.
Like I said, it's a
single Java binary,
about 1,000 instances backed
by around 200 MySQL instances.
Those MySQL sequences are
mostly sharded by user data.
So if a request comes in,
I can get all of my data
from one shard.
We have a sharding library
that manages the shards.
So it figures out where users
go when new users sign up.
It allows you to
expand and contract
the number of MySQL
sequences we have.
And it also handles
caching, for which we had
around 400 nodes of mem cache.
We also have Kafka, where we
do asynchronous processing.
And those messages are largely
processed by other instances
within the monolith.
So we'll talk about--
yeah, we'll talk
about our users now.
Now that we know what the
application looks like,
we thought about what it
would look like for us to move
and who we should be thinking
about as we're moving.
The most important stakeholder
in the move is your users.
Sometimes, doing the
best thing for your users
is not the most easy
thing technically.
But that should be the
thing you do first,
or the person you
think about first.
So, how do we get to GCP
with our users in mind?
We thought about two
different ways of doing this.
One was to do it progressively,
so move user by user,
or batch of user
by batch of user.
Or we could do it all at once.
There are different
pros and cons to each.
For the progressive, we
thought that anything bad that
happened in the new
environment as we were moving,
any new challenge that we
experienced in our new home
would be limited to only
the users that have moved.
So it should be a smaller
impact overall to our user base
as we figured out things
in the new environment.
Secondly, outside of normal
availability problems,
just how our application tended
to load in the new environment
would be able to be observed
in a more gradual fashion.
We could see how the
environment dealt with new load
in a more measured way.
We knew that network
calls-- we wouldn't
be able to make every network
call be in the new data
center in GCP.
So we would have to go back to
the old data center sometimes,
and that would incur
a lot of latency.
That's not a great
user experience,
but it's one of the
downsides of this approach.
And then lastly, we'd have to
operate two full application
stacks simultaneously,
be able to operate them
at the same time and manage them
at the same time in two data
centers and two different
hosting [INAUDIBLE] for us.
On the contrary, the
all-at-once solution--
any challenges you have in
the new environment, when
you cut over to the
new environment,
it affects everyone.
So if you have a big
outage, everyone's down.
It's basically a
total system shock.
There's a lot of risk in that.
You can do a lot of
testing beforehand,
but you don't know what's
really going to happen
until you flip the switch.
The positive is that once
you're in the new data center,
all of your network
calls are local,
so your latency situation is
as good as it's going to be.
And while you don't have to
maintain and operate two data
centers at the
same time, you need
the old one on standby
in case something
goes wrong in the move.
So you're not really
getting rid of the old one
when you cut over, at least
until you're fully in.
So, which one did we choose?
We felt that overall,
thinking of the users in mind,
that the progressive
migration was going
to be much better for them.
On average, most users wouldn't
experience any downtime
or any noticeable downtime.
That took some
work, but we thought
that if we could
slowly roll into GCP,
we would give our users
the best experience,
and maybe even one
they don't notice.
So, as we were
thinking about how
we were going to do this
progressive migration,
we had to think about, what are
the things we want out of it?
How are we going to do it?
What were going to be
our guiding principles?
So, the first one was to make
our best effort to route users
to the environment where
their data is resident.
As I said, we shard
our data out by user.
So, if I move my data from
our old hosting to GCP,
I should start routing
my requests to GCP.
That was the goal of this
migration, is to move
the user with the data.
We wanted to make
sure that-- let's say
we didn't route correctly
in my data is in GCP,
but I got routed to
the old data center.
Well, that should still work.
We still want that
to be an experience.
We don't want to be throwing
errors when we have a misroute.
So we want an experience
no matter what.
We want to be able
to move users to GCP,
but if things aren't
going well, we
need to be able
to move them back.
And we also need to be able
to move at variable speed.
If things are going
great, we should
be able to move
users more quickly.
If they're not going so
well, or we're not sure,
we should trickle them in and
get our sea legs, as it were.
Lastly, as we're making
these decisions about fast,
slow, forward,
backwards, we don't
want to be making a lot
of gut-check decisions.
We want to be able
to look at a chart
and say we're
meeting in our SLOs.
We're going to have
to move forward now.
And so, we actually needed
to develop more SLOs
and have a better handle on
them before we could do this
appropriately.
Let's talk about the
timeline for this migration.
So as I said, we wanted
to move users slow
and quickly, at
different varying times.
But before that, we needed
to actually set everything up
in GCP and make
sure it was working.
And you can always run tests,
but until you're really
routing production users
there, it's not real.
So, the first users that
we routed were employees.
We routed them through GCP.
All their data was still
in our old data center.
They had slow experiences,
but at the beginning,
a lot of things were
broken, but we fixed bugs
until we had a
complete experience.
And all the
meaningful experiences
that happened in Fitbit
were serviceable by going
through GCP, and even if data
was in another data center.
Once we felt
confident in that, we
decided it was time to start
moving paying customers.
So we started moving
users slowly--
in a slow trickle.
When we got to
watches, our systems
took on that new
traffic and made sure
that we were able to
operate and monitor
and really made sure that
things were working in GCP.
Then, once we got a
lot of confidence,
we started moving
users in big batches.
We moved them quickly.
And as you'll see, quicker
than we even anticipated.
So, how did we change d
architecture and technology
to make this kind
of move possible?
As you'll see on the left,
I have the same diagram
for our monolithic architecture,
for our legacy data center.
We replicated that in
Google Cloud Platform,
set the whole thing up.
We had fewer applications
at the start and fewer MySQL
instances.
And those MySQL
instances were empty
when we started as well because
they had no data in them.
There was no data in GCP yet.
And then, we had connections
from all the application
instances to all the MySQLs,
in both the old data center
and in GCP.
So it fully connected
between those two data
centers between
application instances.
Those are the blue
lines you'll see.
The application
instances go to--
those are the lines
that we had to add.
We had to add connections
back to the old data center
from GCP, and to GCP
from the old data center.
Then we added edge
routing as well.
This was the logic that
would allow us to route users
based on where they lived.
So we had to be able to
push that logic somewhere.
It turns out we used
Cloudflare, which
is a CDN and DNS provider.
They had a product
called Cloudflare Workers
that we were able
to push logic up
into and make these decisions.
And I'll talk more
about that later.
But that made it
so that we didn't
have to go into one data
center to decide that we really
wanted to service it
out of the other one,
and kick it back, and redirect.
It made everything much cleaner
and easier to observe as well.
And then, lastly, we have
connectivity between our mem
cache instances.
You'll notice that the
app, in this diagram,
the applications only talk to
their data center local mem
cached, but if one application--
if one data center makes
changes to its
local mem cache, we
want that change to be
replicated to the other one.
And so, we introduced
a proxy that
would allow us to echo in
validations to the other data
center.
I'll talk about that as well.
First, we'll talk
about moving our users.
I said, we had,
initially, empty databases
in GCP and all
our full databases
in our legacy data center.
In our sharding scheme, we
have this notion of buckets.
Buckets have users in them.
Mostly, there's only really
two ways to do sharding.
There's buckets and
there's ID ranges.
We used buckets as kind
of like a hashing scheme.
But it allows us to move
an individual bucket
one at a time.
So we can move one bucket to
any other database server.
So when we were
moving into GCP, we
could move one bucket from
a database server that
lived in our old
data center, and then
move it to GCP now that
users have been moved.
This is the slow
method of movement.
It takes about 20
minutes because there's
a lot of locking involved.
Users can still read
their data, but they can't
write for that 20 minutes.
It's slow and gradual.
We can add parallelism to get
a little bit more speed so we
can do many buckets at a time.
But we can't really move
tons of users at once.
To move fast, move
the whole shard.
And this is a typical
replication strategy,
which is that our
leader database would
be in our old data center.
We'd have a replica
of it in GCP.
At some point, we would flip
who the leader was and make
the leader the one in GCP.
Now, all the users on that
shard, all those buckets
have shifted all at once.
And that is a very fast thing.
It takes about five minutes.
It can go back and forward.
Both of them are
bi-directional, which
is important for our use case.
I'll talk a little
bit about routing.
As I said, Cloudflare
Workers is the technology
we used to provide some
logic as to where our users'
traffic should be routed.
So, we have this idea of
buckets, as I told you about.
There's a finite
number of buckets.
In fact, the number
was finite enough
that we could make
a big map of it
and push that map in
a JavaScript binary
up to this Cloudflare Worker.
We could also put a whitelist
in there, which allowed us--
it was how we were
able to route employees
before paying customers.
So regardless of where
your data is resident,
we could say, oh, this
user should always
go to GCP no matter what, no
matter where their data is--
otherwise, see where
their bucket lives.
So this is the flow diagram.
We have timed
deployments of the logic.
The code that executes
the logic, but also
the data that feeds
that logic gets time
deployed into Cloudflare.
Then the logic is simply, is
the user in the whitelist?
If so, send them to GCP.
If not, check where
their bucket lives.
Is the bucket in GCP?
If yes, send them to GCP.
If not, or we have
some kind of error,
or there is no user
information, send them
to the legacy data center.
Eventually, once we had more
than 50% of movement into GCP,
we made the default GCP.
The last technical aspect was
keeping the caches coherent.
As I said, applications only
talk to their local caches.
And if the other
data center changes
the cache on their
side, you want it
to be reflected in both places.
So we introduced a new
piece of technology
[INAUDIBLE] router and open
source mem cache proxy that
has the ability to echo
deletes and other operations
to other data centers, or other
clusters of mem cache nodes.
Our second cluster just happened
to be at the other data center.
So, this was pretty
challenging for us.
Although it's pretty
straightforward
and it's a good tool, we don't
think a lot about it now.
It was a stark difference
from implementing the routing
from before.
The routing, being
a managed service,
ended up being really
easy for us to do.
It gave us very few headaches,
we had very few incidents
around it.
Whereas, introducing a
new piece of technology
just before you make a big
move was much more challenging
and ended up working out for us.
But it started to show us
the differences between what
might be possible when we
have more managed services
at our disposal.
So, how did this all go?
It actually went quite well,
better than, I think, any of us
expected.
The routing of employees
before everyone else
uncovered many critical bugs.
So it uncovered around 60 bugs.
We closed 58 of them before
we moved to a paying customer.
And I think those other two
got closed as a won't fix.
They didn't end up
being that critical.
So really, everything
that was really
blocking an experience
in GCP was closed
before we were able to do it.
And we did that live.
We did it in production.
I mean, we tested
it in production
without affecting
our paying customers,
which was super awesome.
And then, we also
finished early.
We had a pretty hard deadline
to be out at a certain time.
And we started this process--
if you look at the
left of this graph,
you'll see that
there's a very slow,
a very low trickle of
throughput going to GCP,
which is the green line.
And you'll see that it
slowly steps up over time.
And then around the end of
August, or 8-30 on this chart,
you'll see it takes
a big step up.
And then it takes some other
bigger steps up and stays high.
Based on our SLOs, we were able
to see that we were doing well,
everything was kind
of under control,
and then we could really push
this migration faster, and get
done sooner than we
expected, which was
super exciting for everyone.
So, what are the takeaways
from this process?
Progressive migration is
based on user data locality.
It can provide the best user
experience for your users
most of the time.
If you have a sharded
monolith like we do,
you probably have some sort
of user sharding or something
like that.
And so, if you can do
it little by little,
that's going to be the
best bang for your buck.
Your movement should
have options, both speed
and direction.
It gives you flexibility
for when things go wrong
or things go really well.
Decide what is really good or
really well based on your SLOs.
And then also, we found that
this was the first opportunity
for us having been in our own
colo to use managed services
and really see the
benefit of them.
Now that we're in
Google Cloud Platform,
we think there's a
lot more opportunities
for us to do that.
So, if there are opportunities
to use them in your migration,
I would say you should.
That's all.
Thank you very
much for your time.
And I hope your migration
goes well as well.